[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation je suis
aujourd'hui avec Olivier Jérôme
président de l'association sérum une
association de santé masculine en France
et partenaire de mauvais beurre bonjour
alors les cancers masculins sont de plus
en plus médiatisés la sensibilisation et
la prévention se développent de plus en
plus face à un sujet qui reste encore ta
bouche et de nombreux hommes grâce au
mouvement movvember le mois de novembre
est placé sous le signe des cancers
masculins pour autant l'information et
la prévention doivent se faire tout au
long de l'année vous êtes donc le
président de l'association sérum
pouvez-vous nous en dire un petit peu
plus sur les objectifs de cette
association alors sérum justement a pour
but de faire de la sensibilisation sur
les cancers masculins puisque le cancer
masculin est malheureusement enfin les
concert masculin sont malheureusement
pas assez mis en avant les hommes ne
font pas assez attention à leur santé
donc le but c'est vraiment d'informer
les hommes de faire attention à leur
santé sur différents types de cancers
qu'il les touchent vous concentrez donc
surtout les cancers masculins parmi eux
le cancer des testicules avez-vous
justement des chiffres sur le
pourcentage d'hommes touchés chaque
année par ce cancer ouais tout à fait
donc le cancer le testicule touche
environ entre 2300 et 2800 hommes par an
c'est le cancer de l'homme jeune 18-35
ans et c'est relativement simple de
pouvoir effectivement voir si tout va
bien parce que c'est l'autopalpation des
testicules et donc c'est vraiment très
important et c'est un cancer qui soigne
très bien donc en fait le but c'est de
sensibiliser les hommes pour qu'ils
puissent faire attention ils sont
s'aperçoit quelque chose qui ne va pas
aller tout de suite consulter le médecin
et ça se soigne très bien aujourd'hui
alors justement vous avez parlé
d'autopalpation quelles sont les examens
possibles pour se faire diagnostiquer
notamment si on a l'impression qu'il y a
quelque chose qui ne va pas alors faut
surtout pas hésiter des fois il y a des
hommes effectivement qui s'aperçoivent
qui sont conscient aussi des testicules
pardon parce qu'ils ont eu un choc par
exemple ou quelque chose une douleur au
niveau du testicules donc bien entendu
ça peut être une des causes une douleur
au testicule mais souvent c'est un peu
indolore et c'est vraiment
l'autopalpation en termes de diagnostic
en fait on va dire de de de de méthodes
de recherche et rien d'autre à faire il
y a pas de prise de sang il y a quelque
chose comme ça c'est l'autopalpation on
connaît tous comment particules sont
faites donc c'est relativement simple
une bonne douche chaude on parle peut le
testicule et si on a un petit un petit
nodule un petit quelque chose de dur on
n'hésite pas à aller voir le médecin
tout de suite car le cancer des
testicules et le cancer le plus fréquent
chez les jeunes adultes entre 15 et 35
ans c'est ce que vous indiquez un
notamment dans un communiqué de presse
est-ce que vous estimez cependant que
les hommes sont assez nombreux à
consulter un médecin dans ce cadre
malheureusement c'est un peu la
problématique c'est pour ça qu'on
cherche vraiment à faire la
sensibilisation et à former les jeunes
aujourd'hui et moi le premier quand j'ai
eu un cancer des testicules parce que ce
que j'ai eu il y a maintenant un peu
plus de 20 ans j'allais pas consulter le
médecin un homme est fort viril ne va
pas avoir le médecin on est jamais
souvent pas malade donc on y pense pas
et en fait c'est important de faire
passer ces messages-là un homme peut
aller voir le médecin il doit aller voir
le médecin bien sûr pas forcément pour
tout et n'importe quoi mais dès qu'il y
a quelque chose effectivement d'Apple
anormal ne pas hésiter sauf que là ça
concerne le testicule quelque chose qui
est relativement intime qui représente
aussi la musculanité au niveau de
l'homme donc l'homme a beaucoup de mal à
voir le médecin et puis bah le total
passion on se la fait ou alors un
médecin peut la faire pour nous et
vérifier que tout va bien c'est un tabou
finalement qui empêche les hommes de de
faire c'est vraiment un tabou et c'est
ça la problématique c'est que personne
n'en parle vraiment ou trop peu et donc
les hommes quand ils s'en aperçoivent
c'est souvent trop tard on sait que le
cancer des testicules existe mais les
hommes donc on l'a dit sont assez assez
peu informés sur sur la question est-ce
qu'il existe des symptômes quels
sont-ils et ce qu'on peut le soigner si
les diagnostiquer à temps quels sont les
risques si les hommes ne consultent pas
suffisamment un médecin sur la question
vous avez répondu finalement à toutes
ces questions mais est-ce que votre au
sein de votre association vous êtes
justement en capacité de de donner
toutes les informations aux hommes qui
se posent des questions et même à leurs
proches donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui en
fait on a beaucoup d'appels on a un
centre d'écoute d'ailleurs avec des
numéros de téléphone pour pour se faire
appeler on va dire on a beaucoup
d'informations surtout un vécu et je
pense que c'est important on n'est pas
là pour remplacer les médecins on
travaille avec des médecins mains dans
la main pour accompagner éventuellement
des jeunes qui se posent des questions
ou leur entourage parce que souvent
c'est l'entourage qui appelle c'est même
pas la personne concernée qui ose
peut-être pas trop en parler c'est
l'entourage donc oui beaucoup
d'informations sur ça et surtout quelque
chose de simple d'aller voir le médecin
mais quelque chose qui va pas tout
simplement et quels sont vos actions de
sensibilisation justement pour pour
toucher le plus d'hommes possible alors
aujourd'hui et depuis maintenant
quelques années je crois qu'on a fait on
a sorti des spots de sensibilisation qui
s'appelle un vrai film de boule donc ça
avait pas mal marqué les esprits à
l'époque c'est en 2018 le tout premier
donc sur la sur le bowling enfin la
première c'était la pétanque donc après
un film debout bien entendu ça fait
parler mais c'était le but sur les
réseaux sociaux aussi de choses comme ça
donc de faire un petit spot qui durait
entre 30 secondes et une minute pour
pouvoir faire parler des cancers
masculins ou c'était des équipes qui
jouaient
la première pardon c'était la pétanque
et un deuxième il y a deux ans après sur
le bowling et donc des gens qui jouent
et qui se disent attention fais gaffe à
tes boules etc c'est un moyen
effectivement humoristique parce qu'on
pense aussi que la sensibilisation
surtout chez l'homme jeune peut se faire
via les réseaux sociaux bien entendu
mais aussi de façon humoristique pour
dédramatiser un petit peu les choses et
souvent c'est ce qui a déjà fait parler
parce que ça a été repartagé et avec les
de spots qu'on a dû faire on a touché
quasiment à chaque fois trois entre
trois et cinq millions de personnes donc
on se dit qu'on remplit notre mission en
faisant de la sensibilisation chez les
jeunes par les réseaux sociaux par les
vidéos des choses comme ça est-ce que
justement vous avez on peut faire un
bilan par rapport à ses campagnes de
sensibilisation est-ce qu'elle
fonctionne est-ce que plus d'hommes
soient donc vous contacte soit vont chez
le médecin alors je pense que oui c'est
vrai que c'est difficilement
quantifiable parce que on a on sait pas
si les gens vont voir les médecins mais
en tout cas beaucoup de gens nous ont
rappelé après pour nous dire oui bah
tiens j'ai été consulté etc ou en tout
cas il y en a qui ont dit bah tiens j'en
ai parlé à mon pote il a vu ça etc je
vais montrer la vidéo finalement il
était consulté donc donner des chiffres
non malheureusement on est persuadé que
ça aide oui sinon le ferait pas et on
continue à le faire de plus en plus on a
besoin qu'on en parle donc c'est c'est
bien d'être là aussi aujourd'hui mais
vraiment voilà les chiffres c'est
compliqué mais en tout cas oui ça
fonctionne bien et récemment vous avez
publié une nouvelle campagne sur sur les
réseaux sociaux vous l'avez appelé des
Dick pics pour la bonne cause elle a été
effectivement lors de la semaine de
sensibilisation contre le cancer des
testicules quels sont les objectifs de
cette campagne de communication alors là
on a voulu taper encore un petit peu
fort avec toujours un petit peu sur le
taux humoristique mon Dick pic c'est pas
forcément quelque chose d'humoristique à
l'origine puisque c'est des hommes qui
effectivement envoient les photos de
leur sexe à des femmes qui ont
absolument pas envie de les voir etc et
on a détourné un petit peu cette cette
façon de faire en disant voilà et on a
créé des faux profils ou quand les
hommes les envoient ont un retour d'un
message effectivement de quelqu'un qui
dit voilà on a regardé ton image c'est
si tu l'as l'air bizarre etc c'est plus
encore une fois pour faire comprendre
aux gens et puis en disant que c'est pas
bien qu'il le fassent d'ailleurs ça
c'est important je le dis parce que
c'est pas on encourage pas les gens à
faire des dicks on a dit voilà ce qu'il
faisait attention vis-à-vis de ça donc
il reçoit un message donc voilà bah
tiens ton testicule a l'air bizarre etc
vrai ou pas vrai en fait c'est le but
c'est vraiment de faire bouger un petit
peu les choses et de les envoyer vers un
médecin en disant voilà c'est peut-être
pas normal vis-à-vis de ça et donc le
but c'est aussi d'en faire parler
puisque c'est une aussi une campagne de
sensibilisation à la fois puisque ça
fait réagir beaucoup de monde c'est
devenu une campagne d'ailleurs au niveau
international et ça a été repris par
beaucoup de beaucoup de d'autres médias
étrangers d'ailleurs moi j'étais assez
étonné de ça et donc voilà ça a touché
là c'est pareil je pense plusieurs
millions de personnes c'est
difficilement quantifiable aussi mais en
tout cas oui ça marche donc c'est voilà
de toute façon une campagne qui a qui a
porté ses le but c'est de faire parler
effectivement du cancer du testicule et
on y arrive voilà et on a parlé
essentiellement du cancer des testicules
mais les hommes sont confrontés à
d'autres cancers quelles sont les
cancers justement les plus fréquents
chez chez les hommes et pourquoi est-il
important de consulter un médecin
régulièrement alors le console testicule
c'est l'homme jaune c'est 2300k de 1800k
le premier cancer chez l'homme c'est le
cancer de la prostate et ça c'est encore
un sujet qui est encore très tabou
peut-être même plus tabou que le cancer
du testicule et donc il fait qu'on en
parle pas c'est l'homme c'est l'homme
plus âgé la moyenne d'âge chez 70 75 ans
c'est malheureusement une moyenne donc
ça veut dire qu'il y a beaucoup d'hommes
plus âgés mais il y a aussi beaucoup
d'hommes beaucoup plus jeunes et on a
des cas de concerts de la prostate avec
des hommes de 45 à ça à 50 ans qui sont
encore à l'activité et avec des
problématiques potentielles importante
au niveau de leur santé et aussi
malheureusement et c'est pour ça qu'on
en parle pas potentiellement de virilité
de beaucoup d'autres choses qui vont
autour et ce qui fait que
malheureusement un homme n'en parle pas
parce que c'est en dessous de la
ceinture et on n'est pas très très à
l'aise quand on a des problèmes en
dessous de la ceinture et les hommes ont
beaucoup de mal en parler donc ce sont
les deux c'est vraiment les deux après
le cancer de la verge mais qui est très
très rare très agressif on a quasiment
pas de cas au niveau de l'association
mais c'est vraiment le cancer de la
prostate qui est le plus gros cancer
faut savoir que c'est comme les aimants
comme le cancer du sein en terme de
nombre de personnes c'est environ un
homme qui meurt toutes les heures en
France d'un cancer de la prostate on se
retrouve 8009 cas et donc il faut
vraiment parler c'est vraiment la
sensibilisation à l'état pur alors quels
sont vos autres actions au sein de
l'association sérum par exemple sur la
recherche etc alors aujourd'hui on
intervient aussi beaucoup dans les
hôpitaux c'est à dire que à la demande
des hôpitaux d'opérations qui se
réalisables hôpitaux pour sensibiliser
effectivement les hommes sur le cancer
de la prostate il est entourage quand
encore une fois souvent c'est les femmes
qui viennent avec leur mari poser des
questions parce que les hommes n'osent
pas en parler c'est prenons l'exemple
sur les qui font beaucoup de plus
attention à elle sur la santé que nous
les hommes donc ça c'est important mais
voilà donc en intervient puis après on
aide effectivement à rassemblé des fonds
pour pouvoir aider la recherche avec des
dons que l'on peut faire à différents
hôpitaux par rapport à ça on peut on
peut justement vous vous soutenir donc
c'est dans servent donc à la fois à
aider à la recherche ils aident aussi à
autre chose alors à la recherche la
finance aussi notre centre d'écoute
puisqu'on a donné numéro de téléphone ou
les hommes peuvent nous appeler pour le
cancer de testicules du cancer de la
prostate et puis ça finance aussi nos
déplacements dans les différents
hôpitaux en France qu'on a une vocation
nationale et puis aussi à réaliser des
spots de sensibilisation sur le cancer
des testicules et sur le cancer de la
prostate aussi on en a fait un qui
s'appelait à deux doigts du bonheur
l'année dernière et on pourra conclure
en rappelant que les cancers masculins
comme tous les cancers ne doivent pas
être tabous donc il faut se tout
simplement se faire dépister merci
beaucoup Olivier Jérôme d'avoir été avec
nous sur sensation je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'association sérum
associations de santé masculine en
France pour plus d'informations on peut
se rendre sur le site sérum.fr et pour
revoir ou réécouter cette émission
rendez-vous sur notre site et notre
application radio sensation
[Musique]